[موسيقى]
منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا قبل
الاوكرانيون في بريطانيا بتعاطف شبه كامل
من قبل المقيمين هنا ولكن التضامن هذا اتى
احيانا على حساب الروس المقيمين في لندن
فعقده الذنب ومشاعر الكراهيه على حرب لا
يد لهم فيها ما زالت تطاردهم منهم اليك
الشف المعروف منذ سنوات بين اللندنيين
بمطبخه الروسي ولكن مطعمه الصاخب عاده
اصبح شبه خلال الاسابيع الاولى من الحرب
فالناس ارادوا التضامن مع الاوكرانيين عبر
مقاطعه كل ما هو روسي
[موسيقى]
ا
يشرب الفولي بوكس
[موسيقى]
وجد اليكسي نفسه مضطرا لتغيير الصوره
النمطيه التي الصقت به تبرع بخمسه وعشرين
الف جنيه استرليني شهريا ولمده ثلاثه اشهر
في بدايات الحرب للصليب الاحمر البريطاني
مسانده للاوكرانيين كما يخصص اليوم 20% من
عائدات لائحه طعامه الموسميه لجمعيات تعنى
بمسانده الاوكرانيين
ولا الكراهيه لهما اهميه مقارنه مع حجم
الكارثه التي يتعرض لها الاوكرانيون عند
[موسيقى]
جروا احيانا الى تبني اراء سياسيه تنسجم
مع الراي العام السائد رغم تجنبهم للسياسه
ولكن احيانا يكون من الصعب عجل انفسهم عن
حرب تشغل الشارع البريطاني وتدير جزءا من
حياته السياسيه
لم تكن تجربه الروس المقيمين هنا في
بريطانيا تجربه سهله فبين معارض لهم
وعنصري ضدهم ومقاطعا لاعمالهم وجد الروس
انفسهم في كثير من الاحيان مضطرين لتبرير
قرار حرب لا صله لهم فيها ولا ثقل لرايهم
في تغيير مجراها من نبض لصباح العربيه
عروم عبد الحق